desde hace tres meses vladimir vive en
el exilio la ciudad en la que era
empleado público ha sido ocupada por las
tropas rusas él tuvo que huir pero no ha
dejado su trabajo
ballack leia lamentablemente ha sido
ocupada no se puede ni entrar ni salir
no lo permiten los ocupantes por esto
intentamos ayudar desde otras zonas
recuperados vladimir es uno de los
funcionarios ucranianos exiliados que
siguen trabajando desde las áreas
limítrofes a las zonas ocupadas donde
los combates son particularmente duros
lo acompañamos a visitar un pueblo a
pocos kilómetros del frente donde va a
intentar reunirse con unos compañeros de
trabajo con un montón así intentamos
ayudarles por ejemplo restableciendo la
iluminación pero como hay bombardeos
todos los días las infraestructuras
están colapsando en línea y me pregunto
para qué como tú reportan sacarte
destrucción finalmente los colegas de
vladimir logran llegar al punto de
encuentro el verde meses no tenemos nada
de hace cuatro meses no hay electricidad
no hay gas ni comida diet
don a quien visita los funcionarios en
el exilio se reúnen en aldeas como esta
para intentar organizar la logística y
ayudar a aquella población que se
encuentra en las zonas ocupadas por el
ejército ruso
stefan en jefe de la administración de
sims que cuya capital exige una
importante ciudad del este de ucrania
bajo control ruso desde marzo ha
desplazado su oficina a un pueblo no
ocupado su ubicación exacta no se puede
revelar con nadie y es neo cupieron
anterior esta área es grande y nosotros
nos movemos constantemente pero no
quedamos muchos funcionarios por palermo
no cupieron el director ya no en las
últimas semanas rusia ha reactivado su
ofensiva en la región de jarquín y
alrededor del 30% de la zona ha caído en
manos del ejército ruso pero los
funcionaros públicos ucranianos están en
contacto entre ellos hacia una
resistencia organizada que mantiene la
presencia de ucrania en el terreno